Researchers in Israel paired the smell of
rotten eggs with cigarettes to form a negative
association to help smokers quit while they
sleep.
And a new aquatic exosuit will help archaeologists
explore deep sea shipwrecks for longer periods
of time.
It’s outfitted with cameras, can be controlled
remotely and is basically like wearing a submarine.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
rHealth is a universal health sensor that
allows people to diagnose themselves anywhere.
Using a single drop of blood the device can
test for hundreds of lab values including
vitamin D, calcium and red or white blood
cells by using nanoscale test strips read
by laser.
NASA helped fund its development to better
monitor the health of astronauts and it uses
1500x less blood than conventional lab tests.
It recently won the grand prize from Xprize
and they say it can help diagnose diseases
before you have them including cancer.
Rescue operations could get a huge boost from
cyborg cockroaches.
Researchers at North Carolina State University
are attaching circuit boards and unidirectional
microphones to the insects so they'll be compelled
to move towards the sounds of a person struggling
or crying for help.
An army of these biobots would be released
to help first responders gather information
in areas they can’t initially enter.
And cockroaches are ideal candidates because
they’re small, hard to kill, and do not
likely experience feelings of pain.
The food and fuel of the future could be grown
on highway algae farms.
An experimental garden in Switzerland on a
viaduct over a small highway uses the unobstructed
sunlight and overabundance of Co2 from vehicles
to grow algae.
Built this summer it proves how highways could
be easily modified to grow food, biofuel,
and clean the air.
Male Bustards are promiscuous birds that may
cure their sexually transmitted diseases by
eating poisonous beetles.
So yeah.
Retroreflective projection technology could
make cars see through.
Developed at Keio University in Japan it uses
mirrors, cameras, and fabric lined with tiny
glass beads to project outside images inside
the car.
Aside from eliminating blind spots in your
car, it could be used to let pilots see the
runway beneath them, create gloves that allow
surgeons to see through their hands, and put
us one step closer to invisibility cloaks.
The Altaeros BAT is a wind turbine that floats
in the sky.
The helium-filled device is designed to reach
altitudes of 1,000 feet, where air currents
are 5-8 times more powerful.
Set to debut in Alaska for an 18 month testing
period, the BAT (Buoyant Airborne Turbine),
will bring power to families living off of
the grid while also providing WiFi and cell
phone service.
Mexican free-tailed bats (Tadarida brasiliensis)
employ a form of sonar jamming that prevents
other bats from catching their food.
And the bertholdia moth (Bertholdia trigona)
jams bats to prevent themselves from becoming
food.
That's a lot of ja
Researchers have devised a mathematical model
for “white smell,” the nasal equivalent
to white noise.
The formula combines 38 different compounds
and so far can cancel out the smell of onion,
sauerkraut, fermented tuna, and even the notoriously
stinky durian fruit.
But right now no device has been built - this
is just math.
Smelly math.
ROVER turns bomb-sniffing dog training into
a video game.
Utilizing the Xbox connect, soldiers can communicate
with a virtual dog via gestures in order to
learn how to correctly lead a bomb-sniffing
dog on a hunt for an IED.
Practicing virtually is especially important
because out in the field handlers can accidentally
un-train their dogs by not being attentive
and picking up on subtle cues from their animals.
Finally, researchers at MIT have found a way
to get inside their robots heads.
Using ceiling mounted projectors, animation
software, and motion capture technology these
holo-testing grounds can visualize a robot’s
intentions in real time.
I’m gonna leave you with a humanoid robot
autonomously playing the Metallophone…
And as always - thanks for watching!